and i have some good news to report
and i like to make two uh
key announcements today related to our
kova 19 vaccination effort
as you know a few days ago after a
rigorous
opening open and objective scientific
review process
the food and drug administration issued
an emergency youth
authorization for the johnson and
johnson
covet 19 vaccine we should all be
encouraged by this news of a third
safe and highly effective coven 19
vaccine
the more people will get vaccinated the
faster we're going to overcome this
virus
and get back to our loved ones get our
economy back on track and
start to move back to normal but that's
one of
my first goals in office was when i got
into office was to say that
there will be a hundred million
vaccination shots administered in my
first 100 days in office
we've got halfway to that goal in 37
days and i feel confident we'll make it
all the way
as i and as i've said we have a long way
to go
but you know as i said from the outset
we're going to use every resource
of the federal government to make it
happen among the things i learned when i
came into office
was that johnson and johnson was behind
in manufacturing and production
while we had particular we had the
potential of another highly effective
vaccine to accompany the two existing
vaccines
it simply wasn't coming fast enough
so my team my team has been hard at work
to accelerate that effort
as i've always said this is a wartime
effort
and every action has been on the table
including putting together
breakthrough approaches and today
we're announcing a major step forward
two of the largest health care and
pharmaceutical companies in the world
that are usually competitors are working
together on the vaccine
johnson and johnson and merck will work
together to expand the production of
johnson and johnson's vaccine
this is a type of collaboration between
companies we saw in world war
ii we also hope that the production act
equipped two merc facilities to
standard necessary to safely manufacture
the jnj vaccine
and with the urging and assistance of my
administration
johnson johnson is also taking
additional
new actions to safely accelerate vaccine
production
johnson and johnson's vaccine
manufacturing facilities
will now begin to operate 24 7.
in addition we'll continue to use the
defense production act to expedite
critical materials
in vaccine production such as equipment
machinery and supplies i've also asked
the department of defense to provide
daily logistical support to strengthen
johnson and johnson's efforts and i want
to thank
johnson and johnson and merck for
stepping up and being good corporate
citizens during this national crisis
here's what all this means we're now on
track to have enough vaccine supply
for every adult in america by the end of
may
let me say that again we came to office
prior administration had contracted
for not nearly enough vaccine to cover
adults in america
we rectified that about three weeks ago
we were able to say
that we'll have enough vaccine to apply
for adults by the end of
july and i'm pleased to announce today
as the consequence of the stepped-up
process that i've ordered and just
outlined
this country will have enough vaccine
supplies again
for every adult in america by
the end of may by the end of may
that's progress important progress but
it's not enough
to have the vaccine supply we need
vaccinators
people to put the shots in people's arms
millions of americans arms
today we brought back retired doctors
and nurses
we've developed we deployed more than 1
500 federal medical personnel you
usually see during national
disasters from the federal emergency
management agency
fema and the commissioned health corps
at the department of health and human
services
and the defense department including the
national guard
with thousands more to come
we're also increasing the places where
people can get vaccinated
we've sent millions of vaccines
to over 7 000 pharmacies to make it
easier for folks to get their kova 19
vaccine shot
like they would their flu shot the
federal government is also working with
states to set up
hundreds of mass vaccination centers in
places like
stadiums community centers parking lots
that vaccinate thousands of people per
day
my wife jill and i just visited one in
houston last week it's incredible
and with this increased production of
three safe and effective vaccines
we have an opportunity to help address
the urgent national need more quickly
and getting our schools back open safely
right now an entire generation of young
people
is on the brink of being set back a year
or more in their learning
you can ask millions of parents they
understand
we're already seeing rising mental
health concerns
due in part to isolation educational
disparities that have always existed
grow wider each day
that our schools remain closed and
remote learning isn't the same for every
student as you all know
our educator is doing everything they
can to protect
and educate our students despite the
lack of resources
and as districts face budget crises that
risk education jobs
moms and dads are exiting the workforce
in astonishing numbers
in order to care for and manage the
school experience for their children at
home
hindering their own opportunities for
and further undermining the health of
our economy
this is a national imperative that we
get our kids back into the classroom
safely and as soon as possible as you
know
back in december i set a goal for having
a majority of our k-8 schools
open by the end of my first 100 days as
president
to achieve that goal i sent the american
rescue plan to congress
to provide vital help to make sure
schools can
open safely reopen safely
essential things like more teachers to
reduce class sizes
more buses and bus drivers to transport
our kids safely
and more space to conduct in-person
instructions and
protective equipment school cleaning
services physical alterations to reduce
the risk the spread of the virus
all cost money the house passed the
american rescue plan last week
and i hope the senate will follow as
quickly and as well
you know also the center for disease
control and prevention
the cdc issued new guidelines on how to
reopen our school safely
it's a road map that will enable schools
if they have the resources
they deserve to reopen safely
i have given those schools a road map
i've asked congress to give them the
tools and today
to add one more tool to school reopening
a vaccinated workforce let me be clear
we can reopen schools if the right steps
are taken
even before employees are vaccinated
but time and again we've heard from
educators and parents
that have anxieties about that so as yet
another move to help accelerate the safe
reopening of schools
let's treat in-person learning like an
essential service that it is
and that means getting essential workers
provide that service
educators school staff child care
workers
get them vaccinated immediately they're
essential workers
over 30 states have already taken the
steps to to prioritize
educators for vaccination and today
i'm using the full authority of the
federal government
i'm directing every state to do the same
my challenge to all states territories
in the district of columbia is this
we want every educator school staff
member
child care worker to receive at least
one shot
by the end of the month of march to help
make this happen
starting next week and for a month the
month of march
we'll be using our federal pharmacy
program
to prioritize the vaccination of pre-k
through 12 educators and staff and child
care workers
throughout march they will be able to
sign up for an appointment at a pharmacy
near them
i want to be very clear not every
educator will be able to get their
appointment in the first week
but our girl goal is to do everything we
can to help every educator receive a
shot
this month the month of march i want to
conclude with this
we're making progress from the mess we
inherited
we're moving in the right direction and
today's announcements
are a huge step in our effort to beat
this pandemic
but i have to be honest with you this
fight is far from over i told you i'd be
straight up with you from the beginning
as i said many times things may get
worse again
as new variants spread and as we face
setbacks
like recent winter storms in the midwest
and south
but our administration will never take
this public health threat lightly
though we celebrate the news of a third
vaccine i urge all
americans please keep washing your hands
stay socially distant wear
masks keep wearing them get vaccinated
when it's your
turn now is not the time to let up
i've asked the country to wear masks for
my first 100 days in office
now's not the time to let our guard down
people's lives are at stake we have
already
we've already and i carry this my pocket
lost more as
of today we've lost more than
511 839
americans as of the day it's got to stop
we need the united states senate to
follow the house and pass the american
rescue plan
because despite the optimism without new
resources
our entire effort will be set back
we need the resources the american
rescue plan and we need it urgently
we need them expanding testing ramp up
vaccine distribution
fund fema and other federal vaccine
efforts
and continue reimbursing states for
their efforts
we need the resources to expand genomic
sequencing
to stay ahead of emerging variants find
the protective gear
transportation staffing and other cost
required for school and businesses open
safely we need to fund it
the bottom line is we need the american
rescue plan
now now there is light at the end of the
tunnel
but we cannot let our guard down now or
assure that victory is inevitable
we can't assume that we must remain
vigilant
act fast and aggressively and look out
for one another
that's how we're going to get ahead of
this virus get our economy going again
and get back to our loved ones so thank
you and please
please it's not over yet great news
but stay vigilant may god bless you and
may god protect our troops thank you all
very very much
when do i think things are get back to
normal i've been cautioned
not to give an answer to that because we
don't know for sure
but my hope is by this time next year
we're going to be back to normal and
before that
my hope but again it depends upon if
people continue
continue to be smart
and understand that we still can have
significant losses
there's a lot we have to do yet so thank
you
today did you receive a briefing about
the border today
uh yes i did what did you learn a lot